schon ex persönlich mein heutiger gast
ist dr heinz wilhelm besser bekannt als
fernseh als boxer er kennt die korona
pandemie gleich aus drei perspektiven
er ist der leiter der kogit 19 stationen
am sana krankenhaus in remscheid er
veröffentlicht einen regelmäßigen
podcast über corona beim westdeutschen
rundfunk und er hat vor einigen monaten
die krankheit selbst durchlitten
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
schöndorf ja wir sind hier in köln ganz
in der nähe ihrer wohnung in einem
ausflugsrestaurant adenauer war das
corona bedingt natürlich geschlossen ist
hier bin ich gestern noch gerannt
die nachricht der woche der impfstoff
von feiertag und kaiser r scheint zu
wirken ist das der durchbruch der anfang
vom ende der pandemie also ich freue
mich natürlich stromer und ich bin da
optimist und gehe davon aus dass die
kollegen und kolleginnen da wirklich
hervorragende arbeit geleistet haben
nichtsdestotrotz man muss ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein warum es sind noch keine
wirklichen daten veröffentlicht worden
sondern erstmal nur die pressemitteilung
der wird von einer 90-prozentigen
effizienz gesprochen aber es geht ja
auch darum ja wie wirkt der impfstoff
denn jetzt in den verschiedenen
altersgruppen beispielsweise dh bei den
älteren herrschaften wo man ja weiß dass
die impf antworten meistens etwas
schwächer ausfällt wie bei den jüngeren
menschen
man weiß noch nicht wie lange hält denn
auch die impf antwort an das heißt wie
lange bin ich auch tatsächlich immun
das sind natürlich jetzt alles fragen
die erst noch geklärt werden müssen
nichtsdestotrotz es ist natürlich eine
tolle sache und es gibt ein bisschen
hoffnung in diesen gerade diesen zeiten
wir schauen uns das mal ein bisschen
genauer an zunächst mal wirkungsgrad von
über 90 prozent wie stellt man sowas
überhaupt fest na ja es geht ja darum
wie viele patienten gerade geimpft
worden sind mit diesem wirkstoff das
waren 44.000 da gab es auch wiederum
eine gruppe die nicht geimpft worden
sind beziehungsweise mit einem placebo
versehen worden ist dann hat man sich
angeschaut
naja wer bietet hier die welle die
antikörper wer kann tatsächlich sich
nochmal infizieren und da hat man eben
gesehen dass ein großteil sich eben
nicht infiziert hat dass die antwort bei
der die mit diesem neuen impfstoff
daneben geimpft worden sind
gut war und die haben sich eben wenig
angesteckt ancona
dadurch hat sich diese 90-prozentige
effektivität ergeben wie gesagt man muss
vorsichtig sein die genauen zahlen
liegen wir noch nicht so gut das ist
natürlich spannend auf den ersten blick
klingt 90 prozent sicherheit ja gar
nicht so gut aber das ist doch gut war
auch das ist richtig gut man muss
überlegen die meisten impfstoffe haben
ja nur eine effektivität von 50 prozent
teilweise weniger wir denken zum
beispiel an unsere jährliche influenza
impfung
wir hängen ja immer ein bisschen
hinterher bei influenza ist das problem
dass das virus immer wieder montiert es
gibt immer wieder neue unterformen auf
das dann wiederum reagiert wird so dass
der impfstoff meistens nicht ganz so
effektiv ist wie wir uns das wünschen
dann wie gesagt hängt es auch davon ab
wie gerade jetzt im verhalten der
menschen ist wie viele menschen werden
tatsächlich durchgeimpft und wie ist
dann deren impf antwort wiederum bei
älteren fällt die meistens etwas
schwächer aus man wird niemals einen
impfstoff haben der hundertprozentig
wird man will das ja hier noch mal etwas
sicherer gestalten deswegen ja auch die
zweimalige wie sicher wird den
gewährleisten dass der impfstoff am ende
nur wenige oder am besten gar keine
nebenwirkungen hat ja also der
normalerweise und das fragen sich ja
momentan auf viele laien wie kann ein
impfstoff so schnell hergestellt werden
man sagt ja normalerweise dauert die
herstellung 8 bis 15 jahre von der
grundidee bis zur zulassung jetzt ging
das ganze innerhalb von wenigen monaten
mann ist aber auf ein zumindest
bewährtes system im kopf zu gehören das
ist eben diese m rna impfung zum ersten
mal wird jetzt an impfstoff zugelassen
der eben auf diese wirkungsweise
basierte kommen wir gleich noch zu
letztendlich sind ja aber sonst die
wichtigen phasen einer studie
durchlaufen wurden phase 1 phase zwei
phase-3-studien in der phase 1 studie
geht es darum wirkt er überhaupt das
heißen kommt es zu einer immunisierung
des jeweiligen geimpften in der phase 2
schaut man nach der richtigen dosierung
und vor allen dingen auch noch mal nach
nebenwirkungen und in der großen phase 3
studie wurden wirklich tausende von
menschen durch geben wird da schaut man
dann die optimale dosierung und
natürlich wie ist denn jetzt bei einem
großen klientel mit patienten die älter
sind die erkrankt sind wie ist da die
nebenwirkung gerate wenn man jetzt den
pharmakonzern glauben kann ist hier die
nebenwirkung rate sehr sehr gering
sie sich zu erklären wie dieser
wirkstoff wirkt aber dass ein normaler
zuschauer völlig aussteigt nein das ist
ganz einfach eigentlich und zwar ist das
rna ist nichts anderes als dass ich eine
skizze kriege die in den patienten rein
gespritzt wird von einem bestandteil des
virus in diesem falle ist es die
oberflächenprotein was in dieser skizze
in dieser rna drin ist das ist
letztendlich eine genetische information
die kann in unseren zellen ausgelesen
werden und der körper baut dieses ding
danach stellt dann fest oha das gehört
aber gar nicht zu mir und bildet
daraufhin die antikörper jetzt haben
natürlich viele viele menschen angst es
geht um genetische information kann das
jetzt in unsere dna eingebaut werden
nein kann es natürlich nicht dazu müsse
es eben einen dna impfstoff seien in
diesem falle ist es nichts anderes als
wirklich ein bauplan von einem teil des
corona virus was er aber eben
spezifisches also an der stelle
entwarnung an was könnte denn dieser
impfstoff jetzt noch scheitern
na ja im moment sieht es ja so aus dass
er sehr schnell von der amerikanischen
zulassungsbehörde zugelassen wird auch
unsere europäische zulassungsbehörde
wird er wahrscheinlich wenig
entgegensetzen wenn sich tatsächlich
dass ich jetzt auch weiter bewahrheitet
darum geht das jetzt erst mal das heisst
zeigt er sich jetzt auch so effizient
über die ganzen altersgruppen sind die
nebenwirkungen wirklich so gering nicht
vorgeschrieben und ansonsten scheint
jetzt eigentlich eher daran wie schnell
sind jetzt wirklich die impfdosen denn
dann vorrätig und wer wird dann auch
geimpft hat in welcher reihenfolge gibt
es da auch da gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen und haltungen
jetzt immer mal ganz optimistisch also
das läuft jetzt alles ohne große
zwischenfälle
dann kann man in deutschland ende
dezember oder im januar vielleicht mit
dem impfen beginnen ja wie lange wird er
das denn dann dauern bis man sagen kann
jetzt sind ausreichend geimpft zumindest
ausreichend von den risikogruppen jetzt
können wir die beschränkungen die masken
pflicht abschaffen
gehen sie mal von 23 jahren aus ja also
es sind ja doch mehr menschen in
deutschland die zu den risikogruppen
gehören das sind knapp 23 millionen die
mir jetzt auf anhieb einfallen die zur
hochrisikogruppe gehören die müssen
erstmal durchgeimpft werden dafür
brauche ich eine zweifache impfdosis die
muss da sein vor ort und da muss ich die
natürlich auch noch verimpft
das kriegen sie nicht innerhalb von der
woche hin dementsprechend das braucht er
mahlzeit und dann sagen ja auch viele ja
moment mal es dürfen nicht nur die
risikogruppen seien wir wollen auch den
wirtschaftlichen schaden so klein wie
möglich halten
das heißt wir müssen schauen dass wir
natürlich auch diese leute geimpft
bekommen die dann im fällig sind und die
dritte gruppe sagen dann im moment mal
aber die ärzte und die krankenschwestern
die sich ja mit den corona infizierten
patienten in corona infizierten
patienten ja nun auch auseinandersetzen
müssen die brauchen das ja auch so
schnell wie möglich also ich bin der
extrem entspannt und sagt wir müssen uns
einfach mit der situation abfinden dass
das wirklich einfach noch jahre dauern
auf jeden fall wird diese impfstoff
keinen einfluss haben auf die pandemie
entwicklung in den nächsten monaten im
winter das heißt wir leben mit den
beschränkungen wir leben mit dem locker
und ein teil der im moment haben wie
beurteilen sie das dann ist er richtig
ist der zielführend er ist eher
angemessen
ich habe ihn zuerst eher kritisch
gesehen einfach weil ich eher das gefühl
hatte dass ja ein aktivismus betrieben
wird das schulden blöcke besucht werden
gastronomie theaterbesuche kultur wo ich
eigentlich gar nicht so die gefahr
gesehen habe
mir ist dann aber klar geworden dass es
um etwas anderes geht wir haben eine
wahnsinnige corona möglichkeit
insbesondere auch bei den jüngeren
menschen die sagen mein gott wenn ich
krank werde werde ich halt krank
insbesondere die letalität die wird ja
immer wieder angeführt ist ja gar nicht
so hoch
also diese corona müdigkeit musste
gesprochen werden und das ging jetzt
eigentlich nur mit einem signal und das
signal ist durch diesen lockt online
gesetzt worden
dementsprechend egal wie man jetzt zu
diesen maßnahmen steht ich habe dann
irgendwann gesagt geht das mal auf das
ist auch irgendwo demokratie das ist
jetzt entschieden worden und wir sind
demokraten gehalten uns an dieser stelle
daran und versuchen das beste
rauszuholen ansonsten hat das alles
nichts gebracht und das wäre wirklich
fatal für die theater der für die
gastronomie mit jetzt zumachen müssen
das problem ist dass wir bei 75 prozent
der infizierten gar nicht wissen wo die
sich infiziert haben
wie sieht das bei ihnen an der klinik
aus bei den patienten die zu ihnen
können
haben sie dann im blick wo haben die
sich angestellt also ich betone wirklich
dass das mehr ein sehr subjektive
meinung jetzt meinerseits ist also
einfach nur meine patienten gesehen
wobei ich natürlich sehr viele patienten
gesehen habe wir hatten in remscheid
eben viele infizierte und da waren es
wirklich vor allen dingen die familien
die sich wirklich in der familie
angesteckt haben die sich auf
familienfeiern angesteckt haben
teilweise eben auf großen familienfeiern
wo dann einfach nicht mehr auf die
regeln geachtet worden sind wo die
hygiene etikette nicht mehr eingehalten
worden ist und wo eben teilweise eben
auch ist dass man so ein sehr lecker
umgang war das heißt wir haben teilweise
wirklich verläufe gesehen wo die kinder
die am wachsenden kinder bereits mit dem
verdacht auf cholera getestet worden
sind aber dennoch die älteren
herrschaften zu hause besucht haben und
diese angesteckt haben und die haben
dann wirklich dramatische verläufe
gehabt es wird ja sehr diskutiert ob es
richtig ist dass man versucht die
schulen im präsenzunterricht offen zu
halten wie sehen sie das ja es ist für
mich da und das ist das wichtigste also
ich glaube wir haben jetzt zum einen
festgestellt dass viele viele kinder den
anschluss verpassen weil einfach viele
eltern nicht in der lage sind ein
vernünftiges homeschooling durchzuführen
zum anderen ist es eben auch wichtig
dass kinder auf kinder treffen und sich
mit ihnen auseinandersetzen also da geht
es ja oft haben selber vier ich aber
selber auf der anderen seite muss man
auch sagen wir konnten ja zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt feststellen dass schulen nicht
wirklich der hotspots sind wir haben es
ja immer wieder verschiedene locations
wo man sagt okay wir mussten jetzt hier
klassen schließen oder wir mussten jetzt
ja auch mal eine komplette stufe in
quarantäne stellen aber die studienlage
ist ja auch da relativ deutlich geworden
wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
jüngeren und älteren schulkindern das
heißt grundschule kitas das scheint es
momentan so zu sein dass von den kindern
keine gefahr ausgeht es geht ja immer
dumm zum einen infizieren sich die
kinder und vor allen dingen geben sie es
weiter bei der influenza bei der grippe
ist dass es sehr sehr klar da können
sich die kinder wunderbar infizieren und
die krippe auch wunderbar an ihre eltern
an ihre großeltern weiter in diesem fall
gab es aber wirklich viele auch gute
studien die gezeigt haben junge kinder
die scheinen sich zwar zu infizieren
sind aber deutlich wie
und sie scheinen noch nicht als vektor
zu fungieren oft ist dann doch eher der
erwachsene der ist wenn überhaupt auf
das kind überträgt aber nicht anders
deswegen ist da wirklich meine meinung
grundschulen können offen bleiben kitas
auch ab den gymnasien und den
weiterführenden schulen muss man noch
mal sehr differenziert beobachten kann
man eventuell ab der mittel oder
oberstufe dann auf den digitalen
unterricht zurückgreifen wenn es denn
sein
jetzt gibt es eine neue studie von
ärzten am klinikum hochrhein die wollen
herausgefunden haben dass ihm früher in
der hochphase der pandemie die über
sterblichkeit dies in deutschland oder
dies da am hochrhein gab nur zur hälfte
auf 19 tote zurückzuführen war
und fast genauso viele tote sind
gestorben weil operationen und
notwendige arztbesuche bei ganz anderen
krankheiten aufgeschoben wurden
ja es wird halt interessieren sie
arbeiten ja auch am krankenhaus deckt
sich das mit den erfahrungen bei ihnen
also definitiv kann ich sagen das wird
stimmen also wir werden eine über
sterblichkeit dadurch gehabt haben dass
viele patienten notwendige operationen
nicht haben und jetzt ist der
unterschied durchführen lassen
also es gab zu keinem zeitpunkt in
deutschland ein krankenhaus was nicht
eine notwendige operation durchgeführt
hätte dazu gehören zum beispiel akute
herzinfarkte ja also wenn zum beispiel
eine koronarangiographie der
herzkatheter durchgeführt werden muss
die bypass-operation wenn sie denn
tatsächlich jetzt keine notfallmässig
war
die gehirnblutung das sind alles sachen
die wurden und werden nach wie vor
durchgezogen das müssen wir machen da
geht es um das leben des patienten
was sie aber feststellen ich bin eben
auch kardiologisch tätig ist dass viele
patienten kardiale kontrolltermine
kardiale probleme zu hause aus gesessen
haben aus angst vor einer corona
infektion und das ist ein schuss der
natürlich vorspann nach hinten gegangen
ist dadurch ist es bei vielen zu einem
sehr schnellen fatalen verlauf gegangen
zb ist ihre herzschwäche stärker
geworden und sie sind letztlich daran
verstorben oder tatsächlich auch andere
gute verläufen einem herzinfarkt
beispielsweise also sehr wichtig wir
halten fest wenn menschen sterben dann
sterben sie nicht weil die krankenhäuser
sie nach hause zu schicken sondern sich
sterben deswegen weil sie selber aus
angst sagen ich gehe nicht ins krank
das ist der grund der menschen die
einfach gesagt haben oder die einfach
gesagt dann ich traue mich einfach
gerade das nicht es gibt operationen
elektiven operationen die können
geschoben werden das ist beispielsweise
da sind ich sag mal nur in
anführungsstrichen die schmerzen die
eigentlich zur operation drängen aber
die anderen operation die dringend sind
die werden auch gemacht so und dann muss
man auch hier wirklich appellieren auch
dass die leute auch nach wie vor bietet
kontrolltermine oder ihre beschwerden
ernst nehmen wenn ich zu hause und
luftnot sitze und meinem typischen druck
auf der brust denn dann geht s bitte ins
krankenhaus und davor dass diesmal nicht
aus das geht nach hinten los
jetzt gibt es ja eine minderheit die
sich zu wort meldet die sagt die
gesamten corona maßnahmen die masken
pflicht denn lockte das ist alles
unnötig was halten sie davon
ja das ja quatsch das kann man so nicht
sagen sondern es hat ja schon gezeigt
sobald diese maßnahmen eingeführt wurden
sind hat man auch eine abnahme der
infektion gesehen und auch ich habe mich
auch sehr sehr schwer getan mit den
masken einfach aufgrund des teilweise
falschen handlings des laien also wenn
man eben sieht das bei manchen die maske
in der hosentasche verschwindet dann
wieder aufgerüttelt das sind natürlich
auch infektionsherde nichtsdestotrotz
auch da ist jetzt eigentlich auch die
studienlage sehr sehr eindeutig die
normale mund nasen maske verhindert eben
doch ein teil der übertragung einfach
deswegen weil ich wenn ich in einem
geschlossenen raum sitzen wo viele leute
sind dann geht die arosa wolke nach oben
oder nach hinten raus wenn ich niese
wird eben ein teil in der maske
abgefangen und deswegen muss man all
diese maßnahmen zusammen als großes
puzzle begreifen und das schützt uns
tatsächlich vor infektionen was ist mit
der idee wir schränken nicht das leben
der gesamten bevölkerung ein sondern
schützen die risikopatienten könnten da
die risikopatienten und die hochbetagten
könnte das funktionieren er wird das
denn aussehen
ich gebe ihnen mal ein beispiel also wir
haben die stadt tübingen des
oberbürgermeister boris palmer herrn
gesagt wir versuchen da einiges die
haben
bürgern über 65 jahren eine kostenlose
fmb zwei masken zur verfügung gestellt
die älteren bürger müssen nicht in bus
und bahn netz und können sammeltaxis
besitz und es gibt reservierte
einkaufszeiten im supermarkt ganz in
diese richtung gehen
generell finde ich das eine sehr sehr
gute idee wenn sie denn noch drauf kommt
ich kann es nicht darauf beschränken das
wird nämlich schon zu einer sehr
schnellen isolation und ich finde auch
zu einer stigmatisierung also ich würde
mich das sehr sehr eingeschränkt fühlen
wenn man mir sagt du bist zu alt du bist
zur krank deswegen haben wir für dich
packt kleine korridore geburt von denen
du dich aber nicht entfernen darf
sondern dass sollten zusätzliche ob der
sogenannte sein so wird das erste ding
rein thüringen frei wie das ist toll das
finde ich super und so kann man auch
weiter arbeiten insgesamt jetzt zu sagen
pass mal auf
aufgrund deiner crew mobilität und einer
vorerkrankung musst du schauen dass du
dich schützen oder wir versuchen nicht
zu schützen immer nicht so also wie das
ist wenn man sich das geht nicht
professor bug.de ist ja so was wie der
vordenker der herrenchor oder kritiker
ich weiß dass sich intensiv mit seinen
thesen auseinandergesetzt haben was
halten sie davon
ja ganze mehr an die thesen sind er ist
ja kein corona leugner er wird ja leider
oft missbraucht sondern er sieht es eben
nur deutlich harmloser ich würde gar
nicht jetzt mal ein aktuelles statement
von ihm haben ich habe länger nichts
mehr gehört wo wir ja doch nun einen
dramatischeren verlauf sehen als zur
pandemie beginnen also die zweite welle
hat uns härter getroffen
ich habe deutlich mehr patienten
stationär zu versorgen ich habe deutlich
mehr patienten intensiv medizinisch zu
versorgen und sehe auch das sterben das
ist nicht zu verleugnen
wir haben jetzt auch gute vergleiche wir
haben erste zahlen jeder kennt noch so
die harte grippewelle 2017 2018 hat mir
pro woche zu höchstzeiten knapp 1300
menschen mit respiratorischen infekten
auf den intensivstationen liegen jetzt
sind es 2400 also es ist schon einfach
eine dramatisch höhere zahl
wir wissen dass wir doch jetzt mit pro
tradierten heilungsverläufe zu rechnen
haben bei vielen jungen menschen wir
wissen dass sie zu kognitiven defiziten
kommen kann
also das sind alles dinge die sind jetzt
aufgebraucht und die ist wirklich
wirklich interessieren ob er das ganze
noch so harmlos sieht als vor knapp acht
monaten
vielleicht hilft an der stelle ein
genauerer blick als bei ihnen auf der
krebsstation aussieht
kinder tagtäglich es ist tatsächlich so
dass eben viele menschen in einem sehr
jungen alter und in einem scheinbar noch
ganz gutem zustand zu uns kommen junges
alter ist bei mir zwischen 20 und 50
jahre alt die ihre mikro prozent ihrer
patienten sind unter 50 momentan würde
ich sagen also august september war es
der größte teil da war 70 80 prozent
jetzt leider merkt man dass die zahl der
neuinfektionen so hoch geworden ist das
ist jetzt wieder hoch shops in den
älteren das heißt jetzt werden so 60 70
prozent der iren sein und dann kommen
die anderen 30
die dann zwischen 50 und höher liegen
die haben dann aber auch von vornherein
oft einen deutlich schwereren verlauf
der daneben habe der intensivstation
ändert so man muss sich das ebenso
vorstellen da liegen wirklich dann junge
menschen mit teilweise dramatischen
veränderungen der lunge wo man wirklich
beidseitig befallenen lungenflügel sieht
mit vielen massiven in vier traten die
dann eben auch dafür sorgen dass diese
massiv in aken beispielsweise
eingeschränkt sind und da haben wir
natürlich die sorge als pneumologen wie
sehen da die langzeitfolgen aus ja wird
sich das komplett wieder zurückbilden
oder muss ich damit rechnen dass diese
jungen menschen alleine so genannte
lungenfibrose bekommen da wird im
prinzip das momentan wichtige gewebe wo
der sauerstoff über ausgetauscht wird
ersetzt durch nutzloses bindegewebe es
sieht ganz gut aus
die ersten beobachtungen die wir zeigen
sie zeigen dass dass sich alles wieder
zurückbildet aber furchtbar langsam also
dementsprechend sehe ich dass er schon
ernst so und bei den älteren da kann es
sein dass sie wirklich noch stehen die
ambulanz kommen sagen ich habe eine
luftnot seit 23 tagen und wir stellen
dann aber fest dass sie von der
sättigung furchtbar schlecht sind die
sauerstoffsättigung wir sprechen von den
happy box von den glücklichen hypo
chemischen also die gar nicht merken
dass die jetzt schon seit längerem mit
sauerstoff unterversorgt werden und das
sind patienten die dann meistens sehr
schnell ins koma gelegt werden intubiert
werden müssen und die dann einen irre
langen verlauf auf intensivstationen das
eigene teilweise tödlichem ausgang geben
wir das mal über wieviel 19 patienten
haben sie in ihrer station
und wie viel davon sind gestorben also
das kann ich ihnen ziemlich genau sagen
wir haben jetzt knapp 100 110 im verlauf
der pandemie habe ich selber mit
behandelt und gesehen
dadurch dass ich nicht immer auf der
intensivstation dem beziehungsweise
intensiv stadt die intensivstation ein
intensivmediziner hat habe ich natürlich
nicht die ganz dramatischen verläufe sie
selber miterlebt aber auch da kenne ich
die zahlen die orientalische selber
organisieren sich da ist jeder zweite
internet ist verstorben was was ist denn
so dramatisch bei den verläufen bykow
witt 19 dass so viele menschen sterben
dass er unglaublich viel dass 50 prozent
sterben ja die beatmeten und beatmet
werde das sind die die stirn das liegt
daran dass co wird sich als systemische
erkrankungen demaskiert hat wir haben es
bisher nur als eigentliche
lungenerkrankung abgetan in der ersten
pandemie und sie auch so behandelt wie
pomologen intensivmediziner halt eine
sogenannte atypische lungenentzündung
auch behandeln dann ist er sehr schnell
klar geworden
wir haben hier veränderungen der
blutgerinnung wir haben hier ausgeprägte
hohe thrombose raten die teilweise
lungenembolien hervorgerufen haben die
teilweise einfach von mitte
schlaganfälle hervorgerufen haben aber
auch zusätzlich infarkte so dass sich
unser behandlungskonzept etwas geändert
hat so wird mittlerweile jeder patient
der auf die intensivstation kommt sehr
stark blut verdünnt wir fangen sehr früh
an eben mit der beatmung es war immer
unklar welche beatmungs form ist die
richtige ist wird jetzt mit dem
dexamethason einem uralten
kortisonpräparat wieder therapiert bei
den patienten die schwer krank sind und
das hat uns zumindest geholfen dass wir
viele stabilisieren konnten
kann man denn der richtigen unterschied
sehen dass die die todesrate die die
aufenthaltsdauer im krankenhaus dass die
schwere der krankheit zurückgegangen ist
im vergleich zum früher also wir sehen
schon dass wir dadurch eine besserung
haben und dass wir viele patienten die
wir sonst von einem halben jahr
wahrscheinlich aufgegeben hätten oder
aufgeben mussten jetzt noch mal
stabilisieren konnten
dadurch ist auch die todesrate
zurückgegangen das ist eben ja auch
anhand der zahlen was ja auch glücklich
ist ja
im vergleich zu neuinfektionen im
vergleich zu intensiv auf enthalten sind
wir daher momentan etwas besser die
richtigen zahlen werden allerdings erst
im halben jahr sind aber rein jetzt aus
meinem subjektiven gefühl ja wir können
da jetzt momentan viel besser
therapieren
wie sieht es bei ihnen in remscheid aus
droht die intensivstation einfach im
chaos unterzugehen weil viel zu viele
patienten kommen nein aber wir haben
schon dazu kämpfen wie viele andere
häuser auch die in hotspots letztendlich
ihren standpunkt haben wir besprechen
uns wir haben natürlich auch unsere nein
aber die kann jederzeit kommen das ist
ja das große problem ja nur weil wir
jetzt momentan unserer patienten sehr
gut versorgt bekommen weil wir eben noch
genug bettenkapazitäten haben kann ja
immer wieder irgendwo ein hotspot auf
ploppen der uns dann letztendlich an die
wand drückt das kann jedem krankenhaus
passieren und da muss man eben sehr
vorsichtig sein deswegen muss sich der
professor jahns uns auch recht geben
es wäre wahrscheinlich in manchen
städten nicht schlecht in die
krankenhäuser durch die möglichkeit
hätte neben betten auch vorrätig zu
haben die natürlich dann auch
subventioniert werden durch die politik
sowie das im ersten halbjahr der
pandemie auch dann auch da war das liest
sich ja irgendwo noch irgendwo
wirtschaftlich darstellen
ich habe es zu beginn der sendung ist
schon erwähnt sie haben die krankheit
selber ja durchlitten im frühjahr wie
schlicht und bei ihnen die krankheit
ich kann es nicht genau sagen bei mir
war es ein indirekter nachweis der
erkrankung ich hatte im mai juni
plötzlich einblutungen man spricht von
kleinen päckchen einen streck seiten
meiner schienbeine konnte daraufhin bin
ich zu einer hautärztin gegangen die
sich das angeguckt hat und jetzt die
diagnose vaskulitis gestellt eine
vaskulitis ist eine gefäßentzündung die
durch ein verändertes immunsystem
getriggert wird also letztendlich eine
autoimmunerkrankung die sehr oft durch
virale infekte in gang setzen und
daraufhin wurde ein antikörpertest bei
mir durchgeführt auf groner der dann mit
einem sehr hohen täter sich positiv
zeigte also ich versuche das zu
verstehen sie haben gar nicht gemerkt
als sie die krankheit hatten plötzlich
hatten sie lange nachdem die krankheit
vorbei war plötzlich langzeit nicht
gehört zu den leuten die einen sehr
milden verlauf hatten ich kann
mittlerweile eruieren wann das ungefähr
sein bewusstsein könnte das war wohl um
die osterzeit ich bin da ins frei
geschickt worden weil ich das schon sehr
lange auf corona station gearbeitet habe
und ich fühlte mich wie eigentlich jeder
andere am ersten tag seines urlaubs
unglaublich erschöpft und die nächsten
drei vier tage auch hat er aber sonst
nichts an
hab das einfach darauf zurückgeführt ich
bin jetzt raus jetzt fällt der ganze
stress vor mir ab und das ist einfach
das zeichen dass ich einfach ein
bisschen überarbeitet war jetzt in
zusammenschau würde ich sagen nee das
ist dieses fertig dieses wahnsinnige
abgeschlagenheit diese wahnsinnige
abgeschlagenheit die viele corona
patienten eben auch beschreiben die mich
da wahrscheinlich gefasst hatte und das
war wohl wahrscheinlich meine erkrankung
muss man an der stelle sagen dass sie
sehr sportlich sind sie waren mal
bundesliga leistungssportler sind
betreiben und nach wie vor jeden tag
ausdauersport also an der fitness liegt
es nicht und trotzdem hatten sie diese
langzeitwirkung
inwiefern trinkt sie das jetzt noch ein
und gehen diese langzeitwirkungen zurück
oder oder bleiben die eben also die
vaskulitis hat mir angst gemacht sie
vaskulitis ist keine harmlose erkrankung
die letztendlich jedes organ system
befallen kann dh da kann auch mal die
niere von befallen sein es kommt zu
einer gefäßentzündung der arterien und
venen die niere versorgen dadurch kann
eben auch mal eine niere in einer
niereninsuffizienz enden in einer
dialyse oder blutwäsche das kann aber
auch überall stattfinden es keine herzen
stattfinden das kann eben auch im kopf
stattfinden deswegen musste ich da
wochen lang hoch dosiert kortison
systemisch zu mir nehmen also in
tablettenform was natürlich nicht
unbedingt mein wunsch war und ich habe
eben auch noch post infektions mir ein
belastungs asma angelacht sprich ich
muss auch jetzt immer noch einen
kortison sprechen wenn ich
beispielsweise sport treiben möchte das
ist übrigens auch ein phänomen was wir
momentan bei vielen vielen anderen
gerade jungen menschen feststellen
wir dürfen ja noch nicht von langzeit
folgen reden dafür ist das ganze noch zu
kurz bedürfen noch nicht sagen dass
corona auf jeden fall etwas nach sich
zieht aber professor welte zum beispiel
hat sich dazu hinreißen lassen als er
schätzt ein bis drei prozent aller
menschen mit einer krone infektion
werden wahrscheinlich neue krankheiten
generieren beziehungsweise haben einen
sehr langsamen heilungsverlauf und hier
die uni kliniken können manchmal eine
ganz ganz spannende studie
hier werden hochleistungs athleten
sportler kadersportler olympioniken die
in dem letzten halben jahr an corona
krank waren nach kontrolliert die werden
regelmäßig eingestellt kommen
verschiedene untersuchungen des
herz-kreislauf-systems weil eben auch da
die frage bestand warum brauchen die so
lange um sich zu erholen und warum haben
nach wie vor viele sportler noch
subjektive probleme wie luft hunger
luftnot leistungsminderung häufig sogar
bundesliga-profis da ist alles bunt für
mich dabei wie gesagt da sind
olympioniken hochleistungssportler bei
und das sind natürlich das ist natürlich
eine ganz spannende studie weil die ja
letztlich das brennglas darstellen man
kann natürlich auch sehr viel auf uns
normal sportler dann auch ableiten
der bundespräsident hat sich auch mit
den langzeitfolgen beschäftigt er hat
einige ehemalige cupid patienten
eingeladen und sich über den
krankheitsverlauf berichten was du da
waren sie auch dabei vor ein paar tagen
was haben sie denn den bundespräsidenten
erzählt es war ein sehr schönes ein sehr
informatives gespräch ich fand das sehr
spannend es waren letztendlich mit mir
fünf personen eingeladen die ganz
unterschiedliche verläufe gezeigt haben
da war ein journalist dabei der einen
dramatischen verlauf hatte ein älterer
patient ein älterer mensch der
letztendlich aufrecht in die ambulanz
reihen marschiert ist und fünf stunden
später intubiert war wochenlang im
künstlichen koma war ein sehr sehr
langes rehabilitationsprogramm hinter
sich gebracht habe da waren zwei damen
die die typischen geschmacks und rhi
störungen beschrieben haben und eben
mike singer einen popsong leiter der
eben auch trotzdem hat 22 jahre sehr
sehr betroffen war von der ganzen
geschichte und mir war es eben sehr sehr
wichtig noch mal darauf hinzuweisen wir
dürfen die gefährlichkeit des virus
nicht anhand seiner vitalität nur gesetz
machen sondern eben was es mit uns macht
in den wochen und monaten danach und
wenn man einfach sieht wie viele junge
menschen da auch ihr leiter anziehen
dann würde ich mal sagen ist das schon
ein ding dass wir ernst nehmen sollen
und da war mir da wo es ging um die
impfpflicht sondern menschen zwingen
dazu und ich bin natürlich ein klarer
gegner von zwang sondern da hilft nur
immer wieder aufklärung transparente
aufklärung und in der diskussion durfte
ich dann auch noch mal kritisieren dass
ich eben viele sachen die von der
politik bestimmt werden einfach nicht
verstehe und viele andere verstehen sie
eben auch nicht also beispielsweise
warum werden gastronomien geschlossen
warum wird das theater geschlossen
der große discounter dürfen am
wochenende einen verkaufsoffenen sonntag
machen wo man ja dann auch wieder viele
menschen hat und es war ein wirklich
informatives gespräch wo wir glaube ich
auch einen guten konsens gefunden haben
zum schluss noch ein paar eindrücke zu
ihnen persönlich sie machen persönlich
gar nicht so den eindruck den man
normalerweise von einem arzt hatte mit
de poste war jetzt sony sie die lockere
sprache sind sie einfach anders oder
wollen sie auch ein anderes bild vom
arzt vermitteln
definitiv nicht spielen nichts vor das
könnte ich gar nicht sondern hier sitzen
tatsächlich dr heinz lms boxer
heilwässer ich bin so wie ich bin ich
rede frei nach schnauze mein anliegen
war es aber immer dass ich versuche
informationen runter zu brechen für alle
dass alle da wissen wo es vorne ist wie
es funktioniert und wenn mich die leute
so wahrnehmen wenn die leute mich als
kredite wahrnehmen dann freut mich das
natürlich sehr aber ich würde mir nie so
was sie aufziehen nur um menschen mit zu
schwimmen
aber es gibt ja immer noch so dieses
bild von den halbgöttern in weiß
ist es schädlich oder wie ich bin kein
freund von also ich versuche jeden
menschen abzuholen auf augenhöhe ich
muss nicht als herr obermedizinalrat drs
angesprochen werden mir wäre es
eigentlich wichtiger wenn die leute
nicht als so eine vertrauensvolle person
annehmen dass sie tatsächlich ihr leben
vielleicht ein bisschen verändern es ist
mir immer ein großes anliegen gerade
unsere wohlstand syndrome anzugehen wir
vergessen neben corona das ja noch an
vielen anderen dingen sterben können und
wenn ich mir einfach überlege das
aktuell zwei drittel aller männer und
viele viele frauen einfach massiv zu
dick sind und dadurch wirklich viele
andere erkrankungen sich an lachen wie
bluthochdruck oder bewegungsmangel oder
diabetes mellitus typ 2
dann sind das dinge wenn ich dann solche
menschen überzeugen kann es ist toll
wenn du dich etwas gesünder ernährt ist
es super wenn du dich bewegst und die
nehmen erst ab dann ist mainz ii
gelungen und das ist mir viel wichtiger
als eben der halbgott in weiß
das war für mich persönlich heute mit dr
heinz wilhelm esser herzlichen dank
vielen dank
phoenix persönlich sehen wollen gibt es
regelmäßig im phoenix programm und immer
auf phoenix de und auf youtube bleiben
sie sind
[Musik]